Mahmoud Jamal's face is etched in pain
too tired and sick to speak his has been
a life of displacement
forced to leave Palestine when Israel
was created in 1948 Mahmoud is now
living on the street outside a mosque
like hundreds of refugees forced to
escape fighting between factions inside
lebanon's largest camp for Palestinians
we have been disgraced it is not easy to
live outside one's home many left their
homes Barefoot isn't it enough that our
grandparents were forced from their
homes
some were trapped for days inside what
has become an urban Battleground a
killing on Saturday sparked the latest
bout of factional fighting between fatah
and Shem along with other groups
automatic weapons rocket fire are being
used in the narrow streets where tens of
thousands of Palestinians live
it's very difficult to reach the wounded
and the sick because of the fighting
there are a lot of homes that have been
damaged and destroyed there are many
children caught in the crossfire
the Lebanese Army man's checkpoints
around the camp but it doesn't enter as
part of a decades-old agreement
side security is in the hands of rival
Palestinian factions they've been locked
in a struggle for dominance in the camp
for years and more often than not bouts
of violence are driven by divisive
politics among the Palestinian
leadership abroad even before the latest
security breakdown Palestinians were
living in misery in poverty and denied
rights in an unwelcoming Country and
terrifying life because they always
clash with each other this is not the
first time grenades always land on our
roofs
a ceasefire May silence the guns but it
won't end a reality the lack of unity
means more episodes of violence even
brief will worsen an already dire
humanitarian
crisisera on the outskirts of einel
hallway foreign